comme tous les soirs à neauphle-le-vieux
aurélie et gaëlle perron accueillent
leur fille qui rentre de sa journée en
institut léana 11 ans est handicapée
elle est atteinte du syndrome cardio
faciaux cutanées c'est un syndrome très
rare en fait et qui impacte à la fois
dans sa peau son coeur et heureusement
pour nous les anna oxa sauf au niveau
cardiaque au niveau cutané n'a pas de
problème particulier
par contre au niveau de la nourriture de
l'oralité c'est très compliqué
puisqu'elle est nourri par une sonde
déjà parents de matisse 15 ans aurélie
et gaëlle accueille des jumeaux en 2009
nathan et léana cette deuxième grossesse
change alors complètement la parentalité
du couple disons que avec avec son grand
frère
on avait entre guillemets nos habitudes
donc nous d'avoir des jumeaux c'est pas
quelque chose qui nous faisait forcément
peur mais après forcément avec le
handicap ça remet tout en question et
puis c'est des nouvelles habitudes avec
les annales du jour au lendemain tout
peut s'accélérer donc ces êtres savoir
s'adapter et travailler en équipe
je pense que la résilience est quelque
chose d'important pour des parents
d'enfants handicapés parce qu'il faut
savoir avancer avec cette différence et
construire la vie différemment de celle
des autres
à la naissance des jumeaux aurélie cesse
de travailler léana a besoin d'une
surveillance constante
hospitalisé pendant les premières années
de sa vie les médecins ne feront un
diagnostic qu'au bout de trois ans une
longue période de doute d'angoise et
même de culpabilité pour les parents ça
a été trois années très longue pour nous
on était un peu en errance diagnostique
on essayait de comprendre la situation
parce qu'on avait une petite fille qui
ne s'alimentaient pas savoir que c'était
un syndrome non héréditaire en fait
c'est la faute à pas de chance voilà les
annales a eu ce gène qui a muté ça nous
a permis à david d'enlever cette chape
de plomb sur nos épaules et de lever une
culpabilité certaine passé le choc et la
culpabilité la force prend le dessus
après de longues recherches léana est
admise à 6 ans dans un institut
spécialisé prise en charge la journée la
petite rentrer le soir à la maison un
quotidien désormais bien rodée pour les
parents oui on va y aller pour faire
face aussi au handicap de leur enfant
aurélie et gaëlle ont créé une
association en 2015 nommé au fil de
léana cela leur a permis de rompre l
isolement
c'était très important pour moi en fait
de montrer le handicap et de plus sentir
en dehors la société parce que pendant
six années je me suis considéré comme en
dehors de la société avec ma fille pas à
créer du lien autour de nous de bien
social et c'est vrai que ça nous a
apporté une force et moi voilà je je
refuse de dire que c'est difficile pour
nous pour ces frères parce que du coup
les annales aux ouvres a beaucoup de
choses à d'autres personnes à d'autres
univers et qui sont très riches avec
l'association la famille s'est aussi
découvert une passion commune le sport
entre course à pied et vélo
de quoi partager des moments hors du
quotidien